[Music]
[Applause]
he's the hall of famer tnt inside the
nba analyst charles barkley joining us
on the program few things to talk about
we'll get to the live tour here in a
moment your thoughts on the possibility
that the celtics and nets could complete
a trade that kd would go to boston in
exchange for jalen brown and a few
players and some draft picks
well it depends on what they're giving
up i mean katie i think everybody wants
kd we can be sure of that but it just
depends on what you have to give up
i mean if you're just giving up jaylen
brownish and draft picks
you do that deal right away
but like i said they gotta want more
than that or they don't know what the
hell they're doing in brooklyn
what if you just say to kd we're not
trading you
like you got a contract
they should have did that already
because that team
they're in the conversation the way they
structured
you know because kyrie's got to play
well next year to get a new contract
uh you know we don't know what band's
gonna do but wait when ben was healthy
he was a heck of a player i like the
off-season additions i would tell hey
katie we're not training you we might
have the best team in the eastern
conference and he's going to say
i don't want to play with kyrie
because it's really ironic the day after
kyrie bought in
that's the day he released i want to be
treated
so that would bring that would actually
bring a lot of things into the light if
he says hey you guys trade kyrie i'm
back in
so i i don't know what's going on behind
the scenes but it sounds like he just
had enough of kyrie that's my honest
opinion
and how ironic would this be if kd would
go to boston and those players who
played with kyrie
uh in boston would then be shipped to
brooklyn to have to play with kyrie
yeah man it would be like listen uh
whatever team katie go to gonna be a
contender can they win it we don't know
that depends on what you're giving up
but
if i'm any team in the league i'm like
if i got a chance to get kevin durant
i might go for that
and i thought golden state would make a
run at this and maybe they do because
they do have the pieces or at least it
feels like they have some young players
some depth there and if you're golden
state would you make a run at kd to try
to win a couple more championships here
well i think the two things number one
i love their young players
uh you know but what are you gonna have
to give up like if i'm brooklyn
you give me wiggins kumunga kaminga
wiseman pool
because their draft picks ain't gonna be
any good yeah but if you give me wiseman
kaminga maybe even moody or wiggins one
of those two
i might give me four good young players
because
you know go to state man they don't need
those young players to play well going
forward because their core is getting
old
and wiggins was the second best player
on that team in the playoffs so like i
said it just depends on what you got to
give up to get kd to be honest with you
then draymond green had a tweet uh over
the weekend where he said he was
watching uh the bulls against the utah
jazz 1997. he said we would we would
crush the jazz by 40 and we would you
know beat the bulls
um
but he did say it's kind of crazy to
compare
you know eras here
i i mean i'm not surprised he would say
that the the 2017 warriors would beat
the bulls if he said we couldn't then i
would think that that would be
interesting or headline news here but
um
we get into these discussions all the
time
dan i don't get in those discussions
because i think it takes you know when i
think when guys get on radio and tv and
say who's better lebron or michael
that's just lazy journalism they're just
trying to get stoked fires out there to
get idiots and food to call into your
radio show listen
the warriors
i love what they do
but them little bodies they got they
wouldn't last in the 70s in the 80s no
disrespect you know you know how many
how hot think about this dad let's be
realistic
we know you know how much i love steph
curry correct
yeah
you think he could take that beating
that michael got against the bad boys
pistons come on dan please stop it
i mean the game was just so much more
physical and i'm not talking hey listen
these guys are great today they're great
today i ain't got everybody think every
time you criticize them you like the old
guy get off my lawn i'm just saying
when i watched that last dance first of
all i played during that generation i
tell people when you played against
those bad boys you had to call your
family and say just in case i never see
you again i want y'all to know we're
good i love y'all
cause those boys are out there trying to
hurt people so
that's the thing you can't compare
like yeah today
you know how many free throws michael
jordan was shoot today
compared to how many i mean james
harden's a great player he shoots 12 a
game i mean but you just can't compare
errors because of the physicality
yeah but isaiah survived the physicality
and steph is similar in size to isaiah
no no those guys don't feel like isaiah
thomas is one of the toughest guys ever
played in nba do not compare them to i
told y'all i mean size-wise size-wise no
no no but but not physicality there's a
difference uh he plays uh like isaiah
thomas went through the wars
i mean isaiah remember when uh he got
hit in the face by karmalone and broke
his whole face
uh but no isaiah thomas played a totally
different game
uh and let me tell you something as
great as steffy is isaiah that would
have been a great matchup right there
that would have been a great matchup
i'll give you isaiah or steph as your
point guard
well i thought that when steph won the
championship this year that moved him to
the table with isaiah you know because i
held those two with katie against him a
little bit but now he's
this is the second time he's led a team
to the championship
so i moved him to the table when you
look at levels in the hall of fame let's
move him to the table with isaiah thomas
talking to charles barkley the hall of
famer uh tnt inside the nba analyst um
how would you sum up this past week with
uh the rumors about you joining the live
tour
it's been very stressful uh not gonna
lie to you it's been a lot of it's been
tough i'm not gonna lie because i'm a
man it's hard sitting back
hearing everybody because i don't know
anything to be honest with you
i met with greg he asked me was i
interested i said of course i'm here i
wouldn't have dinner with you if i
wasn't
interested
and um i'm waiting for them to make me
all for our guests but that's all i know
so far but it's been very stressful on
me
how what are you factoring in with your
decision
well man i love tnt
i love ernie kenny and shaq and
everybody who works down there
but if those dudes do something crazy at
me i had to listen
i mean
listen and i'm not going to get on here
and say it's not about the money of
course it's about the money i think the
a bunch of live guys
they're so terrified to say
it's about the money it's all right
everybody's taking a job for money
you know but they're so afraid
that that's why people don't talk bad
about you anyway a certain percentage
but most people i talk to my close
confidant they're like no man you got to
sit down with them listen what they're
offering
and before you i said i know you love
tnt but you know they're giving guys 200
million dollars 150 million dollars 125
million dollars i'd be stupid not to
listen to that conversation
what kind of offer do you think that it
would take for you to leave
i would be astronomical but like what
well dan i make i'm blessed to make a
lot of money but let's say you made 25
30 like 40 million dollars a year
are we am i in the ballpark of what what
you expect to get or you think they'll
offer
i don't know the answer to that question
they know how much money i make
so because you know i have to factor in
this okay there's a couple things number
one i have three years left on my tnt
deal okay
and
i'm probably gonna lose all my
commercials
uh so those are those are two big things
uh if i if i had to lose my tnt gig
that's that would hurt me a lot but i'm
also gonna lose my commercials and
listen let's be realistic i'm not sure
how the public is going to get about as
far as the commercial thing i might not
get commercials anymore
because i uh so it's a lot that goes
into it but
man i love my job but i had to take the
meeting
what did tnt say about you staying there
and doing both
we have not had any conversations
not one
uh to be honest with you dan they've
been very
been very quiet but
i see this the thing
liv has not offered me anything
so
everything is really just speculation
right now
uh like i say we just had dinner he
asked me as i interested i said yes
and he said i'll get back to you and i'm
planning that pro-am thursday uh up in
new jersey
uh but like i say i'm not
unless they come at me with something
crazy i'm not leaving tnt i love my job
at tnt
what's the criticism that hurts the most
oh there's no criticism i i don't deal
with the selective the prosecution about
things people the public
you know everybody picks and chooses i
just think it's funny they're more
worried about civil rights in saudi
arabia place 99.9 percent of people in
the united states have never been
and all of all all of a sudden they're
worried about civil rights in saudi
arabia that's that kind of gives me a
chuckle i said you don't worry about
civil rights of people here in the
united states but all of a sudden when
guys start taking money they're like i'm
worried about civil rights in saudi
arabia and that just makes me laugh i
said that's why why don't y'all get
worried about civil rights here in the
united states let's worry about that
before we worry about what's going on in
saudi arabia
i i understand what you're saying about
saudi arabia and china and i know you're
a nike spokesperson um and you know with
nike in in china i think the saudis with
911 hits home
with people
for a lot of people i think that's
different you know people haven't been
to china won't go to china uh haven't
been to saudi arabia won't go to saudi
arabia 9 11 where 15 of the 18 involved
in 9 11 were saudis
yeah that's
the criticism
well from the from the 911 families yes
and and they have the right to say that
and i understand that but i don't think
the rest of america
is thinking like that but i listen
that's a fair criticism for the 9 11
families
that was the art that was the worst day
in the united states history and i
understand that
but i don't think it's fair for them to
appear in all that on these golfers
that's not fair i mean our government
still does business over there and then
you talk about these people who ain't
never been to china they buying up all
this chinese stuff
so don't act like you know they're gonna
take the moral high ground i mean we
can't even get a car in this country
because all the chips are made in china
so i don't want to have selected like i
understand the 911 families they have
the right to have their opinion
but
i don't think it's fair to blame these
golfers who are just trying to play golf
you know they're not they're not making
a political statement
um so hey i understand it but these guys
hey they're independent contractors
uh and they have to make money any way
they want to and it's up to them
i keep hearing but i haven't really
heard a true answer and that is
um we're growing the game live tour is
growing the game
well we reached out to greg norman and
he might join us coming up next week i
just want to know
because you're fracturing the pga tour
how is the live tour and i'm not talking
about you i'm saying the live tour is
fracturing the pga tour how does that
grow the game of golf
well i think they have some interesting
concepts they talked about
you know the main proponent of the live
tour is the team aspect
so i think and i know that the pga
tourists actually try to start a team
competition live just got a head start
on them and also at their tournaments
they're really trying to bring in a
younger demographic
you know we talked about at the dinner
that the average age of a pga
fan
is like 60 61.
uh you know i have a this will be my
first time going to a tournament you
know they play loud music they have
people having fun they're trying to
reach to a younger demographic so
i think that would grow the game if they
get to a younger demographic because
you know golf is we can't survive on old
fans
so like i say i don't judge these guys
for taking the money
like i say criticisms come with it i
mean that's that's uh christians come
with everything
uh but for me personally i'm i'm glad i
took the meeting i'm looking forward to
playing golf with a couple of my friends
thursday
and i'm just going to play golf it has
nothing to do with politics and anything
like that and if anybody get mad you'll
get over it
but you also look at there has to be an
asking price right you said hey this is
about the money
right is that what this is going to be
based on if greg norman comes back and
says here's our offer
well listen okay let me get an example
i just hear i i know most of the numbers
that's where i reported
i know you know somebody say phil mexi
got 200 million dollars i'm like you
take that money somebody said dustin
justin got 150 million in bryson and
brooks i'm like
150 million dollars to play golf
15 times a year i have no problem with
those guys taking that money
and if they offer me something crazy i'm
gonna take it too
what's crazy
well considering how much money i make
now
it would take
a really huge number for me to give up
my life right now
i mean
i'm not going to give up my life
for
i don't like talking about how much
money i make
okay so let's make you let's say you
make
20 million dollars total endorsements
and tnt
that's fair that's fair
i i might be a little high on that um
let's say
well just for the record do you not okay
let's get that out of the way okay all
right so i'm in the ballpark
right yeah you you you number one you
got you sitting on the front row okay
all right all right so let's say they
come back and they go
we're going to triple it
you and lim said well next time
if they triple it and next time i'm on
your show
the first question better be charles
what are we celebrating that tonight
that should be your first question
that's been your first question if they
triple what i'm making now your first
question should be hey charles where's
the party tonight
and then you can ask me a second
question after that okay but you're more
valuable
than some of these golfers who are again
i think you're the most underpaid
analyst in sports
you're already generating publicity for
the live tour and you're not even on the
live tour and if you're more valuable
than bryson deshambo or patrick reed
dustin johnson
i mean
that's where if it's not 60 million then
then what are you doing i mean you're
worth that i said dan i'm just sitting
back waiting i'm just sitting back
waiting they haven't offered me anything
i can't believe they haven't made you an
offer
if greg norman sat down to dinner with
you in atlanta at that italian
restaurant dad and then he made me an
offer i'd have made a decision by now
well you might have made an offer and
you go nope you're gonna have to do
better than uh than 50.
well i'm saying
i
don't i'm not i'm not in a rush i got a
job okay all right yeah all right
but listen dan okay what's your role on
this tour
you don't have a tv deal
well they're gonna get a tv deal i'm
pretty sure of that with who i'm pretty
well i don't know the answer to that
question but i'm pretty sure they're
going to get it greg norman had to tell
you that you had to say greg where where
are we going to be able to have people
see us
well i'll tell you what's really funny
this is how full of crap everybody is
number one
there's no doubt in my mind tv networks
are calling him they're just afraid to
pull the trigger okay
i'm gonna tell you how i know to answer
that question
when the story broke that i was gonna
meet with greg
i had
15
or more
prominent announcers
call me saying
chuck i've been talking to liv
we are scared to pull the trigger
the only one who's actually pulled the
trigger is david ferrity yeah so
i know they've been talking to 10 to 15
to 20 big time i'm not talking about no
local dudes
i'm not talking about no regional dudes
i'm talking about some of the most
famous announcers in the world call me
private says
chuck what do you think i said yo man
when they make me an awful uh offer i
will be the first to let america know
but they haven't offered me anything
they said man we are terrified
to go first
and the only guy had the stones to go is
david ferrity
but they're talking to
so i know like say he did not tell me a
tv deal was imminent
but he says we're talking to networks
and i think they will get a deal
i think they will get a deal by the end
of this year i truly believe that
what's the time frame did greg norman
say when i'll get back to you
well i'm gonna give them a deadline
what's that gonna be
the deadline's gonna be thursday
okay
i'm planning a pro-am thursday
when you get ready to tee up will you
know what your future is with the live
tour
no i don't think he's going to walk up
to me to uh i don't even know if i'm
playing morning afternoon uh but at some
point we're going to talk i'm not going
to keep tnt in limbo
to be honest with you i don't think it's
fair to them
and you said something interesting
they've gotten plenty of play out of me
coming to play
up there thursday
so
i'm not just going to be no show pony
well hey y'all i got y'all pub for a
week
don't be wasting my time i'm not going
to waste y'all time but
when i leave new jersey thursday night
when i leave the golf course if i don't
have an offer in hand
it's over
good luck
good luck what y'all need luck for i've
seen your golf game you were terrible in
tahoe
dan you did not pay attention i was
great in time oh my god
if you're entertaining you're not
your golf game is not any good if i
played great and that's how about this i
had three people
said dan can you please get dan patrick
back out here
three people three people said okay well
now you're gonna be making serious money
at the lib tour and now we can play for
some real money as tiger once said to me
we'll play for whatever makes you
nervous
dan first of all chuck ain't gonna get
nervous okay
chuck chuck is not gonna get nervous i
can promise you that
don't go third person on me
i like doing that no no it's not good
it's not a good look okay okay okay i
apologize america you should never
prefer to yourself in the third person i
was 100 wrong then great to talk to you
but uh all right brother no good luck
i know you're struggling with this and
uh i know there'll be fallout but uh yes
yes there will be no amount yeah but hey
hey i'm a big boy i can handle it thank
you chuck
thank you brother all right that's
charles barkley we'll take a break back
after this